how's it go Brett but is Peppa welcome
to uh probably the conclusion or finale
beyond tousle I hate how you can never
know in in in there cuz this is kind of
like a TV series how am I supposed to
know what goddamn chair what do you want
for me uh how much I know you - my life
is so difficult
he's Nathan okay when will I see him
again
oh I don't know honey
it was after his mom has he left his
office in three days his wife back sorry
he loved his wife and daughter more than
anything in the world that bad creeper
and we can try again tomorrow okay
tomorrow
you're confusing the [ __ ] out of me that
creeper what are they call it stuffed
animal look at it it's awesome you get
some sleep you got the point like three
hours before I said um dude what's wrong
with our hair it's like defying gravity
hey we're done
singing a song jeez hey near me no whoa
dude
what's with those creepy as dreams yeah
you heard oh yeah one of the few
mysteries left unresolved let's go find
it out
alright [ __ ] you want you think I can't
open that who do your breasts think it
is riding the comma right now don't
cheat so you have no clue do you
me neither it's alright we're on the
same page at least Ellen Page
okay now you're just showing off your
teleporter skills that's lame
hi if you wanted one something you can
just talk to me like normal people what
you want me to come all right gotcha
gotcha
following we're gonna unrevealed unreal
I'm deal is that how you say a secret Oh
che no oh he's drunk
what are you doing here it's late oh
[ __ ] what's gonna happen to bet
I don't know what I'm doing here I guess
I'm here to consult you
daddy Dawkins looks good with little
well bus or whatever it's called am I
gonna do am I gonna heal your
are we gonna talk to him oh don't be sad
teddy
what did you say it was so quick mommy
couldn't do anything is it better that
way
but did I hurt stop it Jimmy did I hurt
at all
you hear me stop it right now we're here
Nathan this is awkward is fun we're
right by your side this is better I like
when they're like left there or you love
you darling
you'll always love you talk to me again
Jodi make them come back make them come
back again
I can't leave God please don't leave me
don't leave me
I missed so much
Oh
so it wasn't something weird or creepy
or anything like that it's is that we
had some [ __ ] to do when we did it I'm
still kind of black son that can't be a
good thing did you know the Sun is
actually black the active condenser is
static of Qasr stan has been destroyed
in the rift is now inaccessible we're
now are the only nation with access to
the info world America this situation
opens not new strategic and military
respectives
and we're gonna launch new programs to
discover possible energy resources and
develop military applications we've
already found ways of linking entities
to human soldiers and this is just the
beginning now this is more important in
the race to space through developing
nuclear capability we have discovered a
new world of a world for us to conquer
typical American this is the beginning
of a new era for our nation is having a
speech impediment all right we obviously
are not okay with that I don't even know
who's the idiot who invited her to that
meeting anyway hi hey you know what we
should invite that girl that hates us to
our plan to dominate the world meaning
yay she needs to know about it all right
Ryan is here this is awkward I was I was
I only kissed him because I thought it
was gonna die okay
better gun top brass getting you down uh
we are gonna be it ironic
they were busy talking about their plans
to take over the world so I left them to
it we played our part in all of this
how about I regret something I feel
Manila better right we did the right
thing
I don't think humanity needs a third
world war
so what are you gonna do now
normal life leave go somewhere far away
just try and lead a normal life
and what about you CIA has it all mapped
out for me
top tier big car golf meetings but I
haven't given him an answer yet but it's
worth considering listen Joe dia I know
it's been complicated between us and I
didn't always do the right thing
damn right you didn't but maybe we could
start again oh Jesus
I'll try and build something together oh
[ __ ] I mean after all the stuff we've
been through maybe we could make it work
Oh how about we think about it because
I'm not ready
they're just not meant to be
announcement is crying underneath that
eye patch
I understand not whatever you do
remember always be there for you I just
mean it ah there you are
Nathan's looking for you come on I'll
take it to his office later Ryan oh you
know what I got a single malt in my
office that needs Sheeran meet you in a
few
no I don't think I come on don't make me
drinking alone waste of a good bottle
I'll tell you what I'll find you okay
this way Jody the [ __ ] was that all
about
rat defect within an EP
um all right
some decisions are hard to make hi Jodi
however don't speak
I'd rather not talk about it
I get it none of my business
thanks for worrying about me cool of
cordis is his mom Oh Horace a lot of
they always go sci-fi and weird [ __ ] in
the end these are games except heavy
rain it's like someone put a leash on
Craig Craig whatever the [ __ ] his name
is in heavy rain and they actually made
something really cool he might not be
responsible I'm just talking out of my
ass
this is that I really love heavy rain
and and I think compare heavy rain to
Fahrenheit
all right he'll be very similar but call
me when you're done a complete you up
they just didn't go batshit crazy like
Fahrenheit and I feel like this one kind
of went a little crazy again whatever
Nathan says thank you
what does that mean the [ __ ] does that
mean
I bet Nathan has hidden something from
us all this time
that is big-ass screen the [ __ ] is a
statue what a dog is an angel
Jody oh it's so glad it's safe
I hope this wraps up nicely I'd really
do I kept my part of the bargain I hopes
the CIA's turn
it's France to CIA's concerned you no
longer exist
new name new identity it's gonna be
Ellen Page I'd be funny
you're now Elizabeth no God no no
identity in their life
had it been awesome how much money come
on dia you do better for services
rendered that should help make
understood hell yeah gonna accept it
before you go there's one less thing I'd
like to ask what is this what is this
what is this what is this when my wife
and daughter disappeared in that
accident
15 years ago my mother - die - I cried a
lot
uh-huh hanging my head against the wall
trying to figure out why why why them
and never being able to hold them again
huh who's like a wound that wouldn't
heal but then you came home when and I
realized they were still here all the
time near me I just couldn't see
what do you government gave me
everything I needed to study the infra
world they were interested in military
applications I was interested seeing my
family again the [ __ ] are you know there
can be some years but I finally
succeeded in creating this
hello my darlings they don't look too
happy
or
I miss you so much
I can't to see them every day soon be
together how I'm working on a modified
condenser that can communicate with
souls of the informant speaking with the
dead Johnny
if you imagine no I don't if it sounds
[ __ ] weird what do you want from me I
want you to help me talk to them their
voices I want to tell them what I'm
doing until I finish my research you're
the only one that can do it I feel like
I should accept it just to move on see
what they say you know but I don't think
you like what he hears
god I could still not pull this [ __ ] off
bah right Darwin here comes missed you
so much
let us go Nathan
you're hurting us you gotta let us go
let us die you fine Ellen did say that
you did they're being torn apart between
two less that's not true you're lying I
know they want to be with me again I
know they want to be with me
let's try me sympathetic I know how you
feel you know nothing about how I feel
you'll hear me nothing goodbye
I hope you find peace
I know there was something about a can
and no daddy doggies come on you can
still do what's right
you're putting mascara come on daddy
Dawkins
come on daddy Dawkins Willie all right
we just left the office and we're gonna
high-five this guy one three
hey man high five you're a woman that's
really awkward very very awkward hi she
was far away and chance dad Oh short
haircut all right what's our job here
what are we doing
can we go back in and stop now again are
we gonna destroy this place maybe and
that's we're gonna make an Black Sun I
know it I knew it
staff only so it seems the game wants me
to go here so let's just go here
the hell are we staff what was a crap hi
Joey I thought I thought you said I was
free good to see you again
oh yeah no like you put us in a very
difficult situation you know that why we
can't let you go we can't kill you
either I don't know what you do on the
other side so so does anyone appropriate
solution gonna do what they did to my
mom we inject you with a neuro acid
which will put you in a permanent coma
Oh Shay exactly what we did with your
mother yes right you [ __ ] a simple and
elegant wait put an end to our
collaboration goodbye Johnny
this game made for me to hate CIA or
something we'll always am grateful for
your help
how is wrong with governments why they
got a do they well it's obviously not
gonna happen
items not gonna let it happen oh [ __ ] it
is happening
jadi that daddy Dafoe opened my eyes it
was so obvious but I didn't want to see
oh good I'm going to accomplish man's
oldest dream nobody will have to die
anymore no one will ever be separated
again the containment field I'm going to
deactivate it
the InfoWorld will spread through our
dimension life and death United in one
world I don't think that's a good idea
hi beating death Jodi everything is
gonna be just fine
come on dad it fo get your [ __ ] together
trust me I really don't at this point I
know that Ty's not fine okay it's all
gonna go to help
we're already seen it anyway but damn
alright fress hope you enjoyed watching
this episode leave a like if you did it
helps me out a lot can't wait for the
next episode I see you in that say
awesome bros love you
even seven what nice toys